c'est la photo d'un acte de naissance
politique
ce 1er septembre 2009 geneviève
darrieussecq était nul à la tête de la
communauté urbaine de mont-de-marsan une
prise de guerre dans un bastion
socialiste conseiller régional depuis
2003 maire depuis 2008
réélu au premier tour en 2014 une
ascension rapide dans une jeune vie
politique j'ai une expérience de dix ans
de la vie publique et à tous les
échelons régional conseil départemental
communes et intercommunalités et je le
revendique parce que je crois que ça va
être vraiment utile d'avoir aussi des
députés qui est cette expérience de
terrain
une des explications du succès de
geneviève darrieussecq et sa popularité
à les opposer
c'est une femme très droite une
dynamique pour âgeuse le prendre des
positions qui ne sont pas toujours les
positions que souhaiterait les uns et
les autres ou la voir se promener le
samedi matin
au marché et profitent des terrasses
voilà il vient dans nos commerces
natif de peyrehorade geneviève
darrieussecq est arrivé à man 2 mars en
1976 avec marcel son époux à leur star
du stade montois rugby
le couple lui kinésithérapeute elle
médecin allergologue a toujours été très
impliqué dans la vie associative est
passionné par le sport et les passionnés
je crois par la vie culturelle locale
landaise donc ce côté la tauromachie
le côté festif une popularité entretenu
par des grands travaux à mont de marsan
les entrées de ville les berges la place
saint roch ont fait peau neuve solaire
darrieussecq
elle a fait de belles choses à mont de
marsan depuis qu'elle est élue la ville
a changé quand même et il le fallait il
le fallait bien que nous les commerçants
nous avons énormément souffert de tous
ces travaux mais aujourd'hui on a un
beau centre ville
certains lui donnent une image
autoritaire tranchantes
c'est une combattante c'est un peu les
valeurs que j'aime dans le rugby est
donc là ils adorent ça et le valais
jusqu'au bout faire un peu mal comment
ils iraient alors et mais je leur en ai
je passe je ne vais bien je sais que
d'arrivées novice députés à l'assemblée
nationale
elle n'a même jamais visité le palais
bourbon